welcome back to las vegas now we rolled
the dice with best-selling author lisa
hawker thanks to smg media group the
sponsors of this next segment rocky
spoke to lisa about her book and
community for individuals in business
and direct sales take a look we are so
excited to talk to you about your new
book best-selling author here and it's
all about direct sales so just introduce
us to the book and explain that concept
okay so direct af sales is a recently
published book that was a labor of love
i started in network marketing about
four and a half years ago and
created a system um that i used to grow
really quickly and had tons of success
with trained a team on
trained outside my team and i wanted to
um to give it to anyone who needs help
in network marketing it's generic it's
good for any direct selling company
um and so i wanted to put it out there
there's there's room for everybody to
have success in this industry so
absolutely what was the process of
writing this book how did it come
together
i put the book aside for about two years
and and one of my good friends said to
me well you know what you achieved what
you said you were going to achieve and
so now it's time to pick that book back
up once i did
it was done in about six months so
wow talk about direct af
right so can you explain the method just
a little bit maybe give us a little
example so the approach behind the book
is just to be direct af be genuine be
real be authentic
no one sale is more important than being
of service and so that's really the the
message behind the book and the message
behind the brand
and i understand that there's it's a
little interactive as well there's
something called your direct af sales
dice right we put only income producing
activities on the dice so
you're focused on
actions that are going to produce
produce results when um done over time
and we gamified it right so sometimes
work can be mundane
yeah
um so just in the morning pick up your
dice roll them execute the two action
steps and
put it to bed go about your regular nine
to five or taking care of the kids or
whatever whatever else you have in your
life in your very full and busy life and
when you go to bed that night as long as
you've done the two action steps
you can consider that a win and when you
do that every day
your business will really thrive can we
talk about maybe
a success story um with the dice right
so what happens is there are people that
are brand new who have had success with
it um maybe somebody's been at it for a
while and they've put their business
down but they want to pick it back up
and they don't know where to start this
is a perfect place for them to just say
i'm gonna do the two things that the
dice give me and then i'm going to do it
again tomorrow
and so it eliminates overwhelm and
eliminates confusion
um it eliminates the guilt and shame
that some people have when they do put
their business down that enables them to
just step back in in a really fun way
that's light-hearted what is the direct
af builders community it's an online
paid membership community the price is
super low up until november one it's 27
a month you're going to get a free copy
of the book yeah and you're gonna
and you're gonna get a free set of the
dice and we have weekly um power
sessions where there's like a q a
there's guest speakers that are leaders
in the industry that come on we've got
tons of training on mindset it's open
for anybody in the industry
for more information about lisa hawker
you can visit her website mentioned
right here and las vegas now